et pour en parler nous sommes en ligne
avec shaquille mohamed ministre de
l'emploi et du travail de l'île maurice
monsieur le ministre
bonjour merci de répondre à nos
questions en direct sur rt france alors
quels sont les derniers éléments à votre
connaissance concernant la situation sur
place on disait on craint maintenant à
une position à la réunion bonjour et
merci de me donner l'opportunité de
contribuer à ce sujet brûlant qui a fait
beaucoup de dégâts à l'île maurice
on arrive à une expérience précédente
quand j'étais au gouvernement un
gouvernement précédent quand j'étais
ministre du travail et cette situation
similaire a été réglé a été géré de
façon beaucoup plus professionnels mieux
que ça a été cette fois ci par le
gouvernement en place maintenant il est
vrai que le ministre de l'outre-mer
monsieur sébastien lecornu est arrivé à
maurice
et quand il était à maurice guerre il a
donné une conférence de presse il a
rencontré les autorités concernées il
est clair que l'île soeur est très
concerné par les possibilités des
hydrocarbures qui viendront possiblement
ou potentiellement pollués les plages
réunionnaises mais nous à l'île maurice
il est aucun doute que sans l'apport des
volontaires des ong les des citoyens de
ce pays
rien n'aurait été accompli et je pense
que beaucoup a été accompli accompli
jusqu'à l'heure pour contenir les les
dégâts quand ils écrivent que la
contribution française était non comment
monsieur le ministre ce que vous vous
expliquer finalement la mauvaise gestion
à vous en parliez tout à l'heure la
mauvaise gestion de cette catastrophe
on a écouté les explications du premier
ministre de l'île maurice le peuple à
écouter aussi les explications du
ministre
environnement et le ministre de la pêche
la grande majorité de l'île maurice si
je peux le dire ainsi n'est pas
convaincu par ces explications
il est inacceptable et on comprend pas
comment se fait-il que ça a pris
beaucoup plus de six jours au hockey
l'état commence à montrer une
intervention sérieuse sur ce vraquier
qui était échoué sur le récif du sud est
de l'île il est aussi incompréhensible
que le pompage n'a commencé cabré qui a
eu fuite de l'huile dans les hauts de
l'île maurice et qui a commencé à
polluer le rivage et les plages de l'île
maurice
les explications du gouvernement sur
leur interprétation des conventions ou
des lois ne tient pas la route et c'est
pour cela qu'en avant que je commence à
intervenir vous avez entendu les
mauriciens qui sont des volontaires et
sans eux
comme je vous dis je le répète c'est
grâce à eux qu'on a pu vraiment trouver
des solutions immédiates et d'urgente
mais le peuple est en colère
le peuple est en colère aussi parce que
le premier ministre et le gouvernement a
commencé à décider qui ils vont appeler
dans la conférence de presse il ya même
un muselage de la presse de la part de
ce gouvernement soit disant un
gouvernement d'une île maurice démocrate
loin de là mais le gouvernement de
maurice qui l'avait finalement les
moyens de gérer seule cette catastrophe
environnementale
il est sûr que le gouvernement de l'île
maurice n'a pas les mêmes moyens que la
république française
n'oublions pas que avec la venue de
monsieur le ministre d outre-mer à l'île
maurice d'hyères et l'appel
que du président macron qui a été
entendu pas l'appel du premier ministre
mauricien qui a été entendu par le
président macron à la fin de la vitesse
à laquelle la france est intervenue avec
d'autres pays amis comme l'inde ou même
la russie et d'autres même des états
unis
il est le gouvernement mauricien aurait
pu éviter ce cas de la catastrophe en
étant en contact immédiatement avec
l'île soeur immédiatement avec les
forces françaises basées à l'île de la
réunion
mais au lieu de cela le gouvernement a
fait la sourde oreille ou n'a pas n'a
pas il n'était pas présent quand il le
fallait
et ce n'est qu'après que finalement il
ya eu intervention mais il est dommage
maintenant la course au tout le monde
c'est de trouver une solution une
solution durable passe qui est clément
il ya eu préjudice clairement il ya
dommages et tout ce qui a été fait va
prendre des années et des années pour
réparer et bien sûr on compte sur le
soutien et le support des pays amis qui
accourent vers l'île maurice pour nous
aider ces paysannes il aide
internationale
or est celle selon vous plus pu se
déclencher d'elle-même et plus
rapidement
l'île maurice est un état souverain et
clairement du fait que cet accident
s'est passé dans le territoire mauricien
et pas sur un territoire français ou
autre il est clair qu'il était
nécessaire pour que le gouvernement
mauricien puisse faire appel
immédiatement à une autorité française
ou même anglaise ou indiennes ou un
autre pays amis
mais cela ne s'est pas concrétisé
deuxièmement j'aimerais aussi souligné
que l'île maurice a toujours bénéficié
nos forces nos institutions ont toujours
bénéficié de formation de l'as pas des
nations unies de la part de la
commission de l'océan indien et aussi de
dons d'équipements anti pollution et ses
équipements là était un maurice mais
comme vous avez vu vous même comment les
mauriciens les volontaires ont pu se
servir de l'ingéniosité mauricienne en
se fabriquant des boudins antipollution
avec des pailles d'appareils de cannes
cela démontre que d'un des dunes par les
autorités mauriciennes ne n'ont pas été
assez à ne pas agir rapidement ils ne se
sont pas ils n'ont pas servi tout ce
qu'ils avaient comme il le fallait parce
que on vient aussi d'apprendre qu'il ya
encore des équipements anti pollution
qui se retrouvent dans un entrepôt au
port mais qui n'est pas n'a pas été
utilisé jusqu'à maintenant alors je
pense que ce problème aurait été on
aurait pu mieux gérer ce problème mais
le gouvernement est à blâmer le peuple
est en colère
merci shakeel mohamed d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
ministre de l'emploi et du travail de
l'île maurice